in this video I'm going to explain how
you can drive a Tesla for free see if
you've got £30,000 which is typically
about how much it costs to buy a
standard Tesla I would say don't use
that £30,000 to buy a Tesla cuz it's
going to cost you £30,000 to buy Tesla
when it can be completely free let me
explain how you drive a Tesla for free
I'm a property investor and I've been
buying houses for the last 15 years I
don't buy many cars tend to buy houses I
drive nice cars but let me explain
something if instead of putting £30,000
down boom to buy a Tesla which is just
going to go down in value and it's just
going to be a liability that you've got
to pay to fuel and fund instead if you
use that £30,000 as a deposit to buy a
house let's say you're buying a house
for £100,000 if you know how to buy
houses smart the right type of houses
you can rent those houses out on short
St lets on Airbnb I do this all the time
you can buy cheap houses or even an
apartment a little apartment on a beach
somewhere and rent out for £80 a night
if it's got an 80% occupancy and it's
renting out for £80 a night that's still
going to leave you with a profit of
around £1,000 a month after all your
mortgage payments your cleaners and
everything with that ,000 a month profit
so you put down a 30 grand deposit
you're making £1,000 a month with that
,000 a month you can now lease a Tesla
you can lease a Tesla from around
£425 a month so you're leasing a Tesla
but you've still got left over5 600 a
month which you can then spend on
running the car uh any any um I was
going to say fuel but it's electric
isn't it a Tesla but still you've got
you've got Surplus money to pay towards
your rent so if you've got £30,000 I
would definitely say don't use that to
just buy a Tesla instead you use it to
strategically buy an investment property
and then with the rent that you're
making from the investment property pay
to lease your Tesla another great thing
about this as well is what happens to
houses in value over time well they go
up historically you can look back over
the last 10 20 50 100 years so if you
own a house instead of a Tesla a Tesla's
going to go down in value it's going to
go down in value it's going to
depreciate whereas if you've got your
money in a property that's strategically
invested not only are you going to be
better off from a month-by-month cash
flow perspective but also you own an
asset that is appreciating in value
historically houses double in value
every 10 years so if you've bought a
house for 100 grand and you've put down
30 grand for your deposit and a bit of a
refurb when that house goes up in value
if the house doubles in 10 years and he
worth 200 Grand you've made a 100 Grand
in equity what can what what can you do
with 100 Grand well that same house that
was being rented out which was covering
your lease now when it goes up in value
sell the house or refinance the house
and use that to go and buy a Tesla so
not only can you rent a Tesla with the
rent you can also buy it with the
capital appreciation so I think the
lesson to this is don't buy cars cars if
you've only got £30,000 invest
strategically into property lease your
lifestyle until ultimately you can start
buying your cars in fact I was 29 years
old before I bought an expensive car
before I bought an expensive house to
live in I bought a house uh about two
years ago for £3 million to live in but
until the age of 29 all of my things
that I was buying was all things that I
was renting out that was leasing my life
so don't just go and blow 30 grand on a
car invest invest invest and the best
investment even better than property is
yourself so if you want to invest in
yourself invest in your education come
spend a day with me I'm a nice guy so
it's just one p for a ticket one invest
one1 in yourself let's spend a day
together and learn all about how you can
strategically buy those types of houses
now you might be thinking but I don't
have 30,000 so what do I do well even if
you've not got £30,000 to invest in a
car or a house you still need to learn
to find these houses because if you can
find these strategic Investments even if
you've not got 30 grand you can then
sell that as a deal sell that property
as an opportunity to an investor and
typically you're going to get paid about
£3,000 per sale that you make how much
money do you need to do this nothing you
just need to know how to find these
houses if you do that 10 times one a
week for 10 weeks you've now got your 30
grand and now you can invest him on
yourself and then lease the Tesla